ihr habt mir wechseln zumindest
teilweise in die innenpolitik wobei der
kanzler von zeitenwende gesprochen hat
und ich bin einfach nicht sicher ob auch
die denkt wende schon stattgefunden hat
da gibt es einmal tatsächlich die
wahrnehmung dass die welt nicht so
friedlich ist wie wir sie lange gehalten
haben und gleichzeitig abgerüstet haben
wir haben die daten sind dann nur von
freunden umgeben nein russland hat seit
langem eine sehr expansive und sehr
aggressive politik betrieben zuletzt in
syrien haben wir gesehen china schickt
sich auf einer etwas stille und weniger
harte art an die hegemonie in der welt
einzunehmen und mache ich auch gar
keinen hehl draus also wir haben hier
tatsächlich zu gelernt wohin wir nicht
zu gelernt haben das hat man bei einem
spiegel gesehen eine mehrfach quotierung
die zu einem fatalen ergebnis geführt
hat es musste eine frau sein um die
quote zu erfüllen und das musste eine
frau vom linken flügel der grünen sein
jetzt machen die grünen genau das
gleiche wieder die suche nach dem
gleichen muster das einzige was keine
rolle spielt ist die kompetenz da wird
von anton hofreiter
gehandelt bis hin zu ricarda lang der
neuen vorsitzenden die gut zu tun hat
jetzt erst mal im neuen parteivorsitz
anzukommen mit anderen worten die
zeitenwende und die denkt wände müssen
bedeuten die welt ist nicht so wie wir
sie uns wünschen sondern wir müssen
endlich die realität zur kenntnis nehmen
parität ist da draußen keine normale
verteilung der gesellschaft wir können
gesellschaften nicht am reißbrett
schneidern und deshalb ist es auch
unsinn so zu tun als müsste man
quotieren für eine welt die es draußen
gar nicht gibt wir können es ist auch
unsinn zu glauben der verbrenner
verschwindet wenn wir einen beschluss
fassen dass er weg ist sondern es gibt
ein anderes mobilitätskonzept ansteigen
die leute um es ist unsinn
atomkraftwerke abzuschalten wenn wir
keinen anderen haben sondern nur noch
aussteigen aus holzverbrennung möchte
man im augenblick auch geradeaus stand
die denkt am ende muss bedeuten realität
first wünsche second
absolut also da kann ich jetzt ja 100
prozent zustimmen das sehe ich genauso
ich glaube wir haben ganz großes problem
das sich ich sage jetzt mal im
politischen berlin ganz viel um sich
selbst dreht und das
innerparteiliche
befindlichkeiten da die große rolle
spielen man sieht seine aktuellen
bundeskabinett ganz wunderbar da haben
wir ein paar problemfälle nancy faeser
frau spiegel ist jetzt weg frau
lamprecht haben wir auch noch da wurde
sogar kommen wird da kommen wir da ich
auch genug stoff für ganz viele
sendungen habe ich mir sicher aber da
hat man sozusagen innerparteiliche
befindlichkeiten quotierungen gewisse
regionale befindlichkeiten er wäre dann
besser gewesen von den grünen als frau
spiegel das ist eine gute frage ich bin
sicherlich kein fan der grünen ja dass
das ist wirklich gefangen hatte was mit
der quote zu tun wer hätte es denn dann
werden müssen also ich denke man hätte
dann vielleicht jemand aus baden
württemberg hoch schicken müssen der ein
bisschen erfahrung hatte ich meine frau
lamprecht fr studio for iphone spiegel
ist ja auch als landesministerin hoch
gegangen aber die war ja offensichtlich
am ende ihrer amtszeit in rheinland
pfalz schon komplett überfordert die
hatte eigentlich schon diese dies war
schon knöcheltief im wasser im wahrsten
sinn des wortes und dann den mut zu
machen die nach nach berlin zu schicken
ist ziemlich unverantwortlich wenn man
antritt im als bundesministerin war klar
dass sie sich vor einem
untersuchungsausschuss im rheinland
pfalz würde verantworten müssen und ob
die nicht performance während der flut
berichte ich mich aber einmal ab ganz
kurz darauf passiert es für diejenigen
die vielleicht noch nicht mitbekommen
warum spiele jetzt zurücktreten musste
es ist ein gemisch von verschiedenen
ursachen der letztliche letzte anstoß
war jetzt dass sie einen vierwöchigen
urlaub in der flut zeit angetreten hat
sie hat das gerechtfertigt ihre familie
sei in einer ausnahmesituation gewesen
das konnte man auch wirklich gut
nachvollziehen allerdings andere
familien natürlich auch das ministeramt
stellt besondere anforderungen das kann
man überhaupt nicht bestreiten und sie
hatte in rheinland pfalz auch noch zwei
ministerien weil sie laut
geschäftsverteilungsplan dann das
umweltministerium noch mit übernommen
hat und war sichtlich überfordert nun
diesen urlaub zu verschweigen und jetzt
erst einzuräumen ist schwierig und dann
in dieser antwort auf unsere anfrage
auch noch eine weitere lüge und dazu
bringen nämlich sie habe alle
kabinettssitzungen per video verfolgt
und dann das wieder zurücknehmen zu
müssen ist einfach hochgradig
unglücklich um es mal ganz diplomatisch
auszudrücken es ging dann nicht mehr hat
mag frau spiegel ja eine konsequenz
gezogen sie ist zurückgetreten darüber
diskutieren ob das deutlich zu spät war
ob das auftreten am wochenende das noch
einmal befeuert hat insgesamt sind die
fakten ja eben richtig dargestellt
wurden und ich glaube auch das stichwort
denkt wende wenn wir über zeitenwenden
reden das genau richtig aber wir müssen
uns ja auch ein stück weit ehrlich
machen also jede partei hat immer ein
stück weit und regionalproporz hat immer
ein stück weit ein ausgleich von
verschiedenen strömungen dass das bei
den grünen auf die spitze getrieben wird
und zwar dergestalt dass denn also
teilweise doppelt regierung stattfinden
das muss glaube ich jeder wähler jeder
wählerinnen und wähler bewährten ja also
am ende des tages gibt jeder parteien
angebot das angebot das die grünen
gegeben haben ist soweit auch bekannt
und konsequent deswegen wenn jetzt nicht
eine ausgewiesene experten in dem
bereich oder experte in dem bereich und
wie in der grünen-fraktion uns allen
auffällt dann kann ich diese kritik
jetzt will die ämter besetzung die noch
vor ostern stattfinden soll nicht ganz
nachvollziehen doch erst mal ab wer da
kommt auch der dann ein recht dass er
sich oder diejenige hat ein recht sich
einzuarbeiten wir hatten früher mal 100
tage das ist jetzt so den letzten 120
tagen seit dem die ampel in
verantwortung ist so ein bisschen
verschütt gegangen aber ich würde sagen
eine konsequenz gezogen wurden das ist
nicht nur einer bei den quoten dass das
thema wirklich allein herr heimat
freigegeben ich bleibe und ja ist ganz
klar die frage quotieren wir uns kaputt
also die die wahrheit ist und daran muss
ich aber leider recht geben und das kann
ja auch für die cdu und auch für die uns
ist ja irgendwie haben den proporz
zwischen oberbayern und niederbayern und
franken und wir haben natürlich auch im
proporz und wenn man sich die kabinette
von merkel anguckt dann waren die auch
alle proporz müsse auch das system dass
jede partei ihre minister selbst
bestimmt also olaf scholz hat gar keinen
einfluss darauf in die grünen nehmen ich
muss sagen ich habe für den urlaub für
frau spiegel ehrlich gesagt mehr
verständnis als sie ich finde die
tatsache dass sie in einer flut das
einzige was sie zu einer
pressemitteilung sagt dass man
campingplatz nutzer gendern muss und
ansonsten hatte dazu nicht zu sagen
stellte an ihr handy ab das finde ich
eigentlich ehrlich gesagt dass größere
versagen weil ich war als
umweltministerin ist man wenn so eine
flut an kommen ist man irgendwie ein
deck als kapitän
heute im zeitalter von videokonferenzen
und so weiter wie sie diesen urlaub
ausgestellten hat ich werde nicht
zurücktreten müssen
so wie das gelaufen ist weil das am
schluss für die grünen glaube ich
unvermeidlich aber ich habe mehr
verständnis ich glaube sie hat er der
umgang mit der krise ist man meistens
das größere problem als sie der
eigentliche sachverhalten sie war olic
eine ist auch falsch wenn man wegen
eines urlaubes in dem man erreichbar ist
und gerade heute mit modernen medien
also ich fahre auch im urlaub aber ich
arbeite praktisch auch jeden tag zum
ärger meiner familie im urlaub und das
kann man so halten da kann man auch
wirklich etwas machen
halt für politiker immer immer
problematisch so
das würde ich auch gar nicht verteidigen
ich bin auch nicht als sie die politik
dafür da die fragen
also ich habe bevor ich bin ja kein
berufspolitiker sondern kommen aus der
wirtschaft und habe
kumuliert viele jahrzehnte im
ausgetreten gesehen ich habe aber im
senat aus und ist als abgeordneter ja
jetzt wenn ich beruflich wollte
verteidigen nein das ist alle gläser
grund diese gläserne decke gibt und dass
die quote wahrscheinlich nicht das
optimale ist aber irgendeine antwort
müssen wir darauf schon finden dass wir
in bestimmten bereichen
unterrepräsentiert sind und wir haben so
steht in der richterschaft und man
positives beispiel über die gezielte
förderung von frauen ist ja heute
hinbekommen dass wir da halbwegs okay
sind in manche berufsfelder sind wir es
nicht und ich persönlich muss sagen also
auch unsere partei unser union sieht
beim thema frauen nicht so super aus
deswegen würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
dass alles
aber das ist ja das ist ja genau der
punkt das ja genau der punkt bei den
grünen sehen wir eine mehrfach sich
ineinander verschränken die quote und
das funktioniert ganz offensichtlich in
vielen fällen nicht aber nicht das
problem der quote ist sondern frau
spiegel hat ein individuelles problem
eines fehlverhalten die suche in dieser
flut krise besucher zeigt doch jetzt man
kann keinen mann neben möglichen noch so
geeignet sein weil ja das kabinett auch
pari pari sich jetzt ja nicht ist ja
nicht der fall lauterbach wo einen
familien der minister der grünen sich
aufgedrängt hat man gesagt wieso nimmt
man eigentlich nicht denen das war ja
nicht das gruppen- und frau rasch und
will auch die regionalproporz sind ja
von hübel es ist ja nicht sogar ein
bisschen quote okay ist und nur die
strafe der grünen ist mist nein es ist
immer mist wenn man es nicht nach
kompetenz macht und ich habe auch kein
verständnis dafür dass unbedingt
irgendein oberbayer drin sein muss und
dann nimmt man jemanden der sich da
mühsamer einarbeiten muss wir haben es
im bundeskabinett an anderer stelle auch
wenn der dritte verteidigungsminister in
folge erst mal die rangabzeichen lernen
muss um sich da 1 arbeiten dann finde
ich das einfach für die truppe
entwürdigend sie haben dann regelmäßig
azubis an der spitze die auch noch gut
bezahlt dann die geschicke lenken sollen
und das haben eigentlich auch wir bürger
nicht verdient aber ich weiß natürlich
dass das realität ist wir möchten wir
jetzt aber trotzdem nicht zu eigen
machen